Transcriptor: Myriam Huertas
Revisor: Anna Sobota
Buenas tardes a todos.
Yo tengo el honor de cerrar
este TEDx UniLeón
y espero que hayáis guardado
un huequecillo para el postre.
Yo voy a hablaros de algo
dulce, pegajoso y delicioso.
Algo que es la esencia de
millones de flores
y que es el resultado de la gran
dedicación y el trabajo de las abejas.
Voy a hablaros de la miel.
Pero antes de empezar
me gustaría haceros una pregunta:
¿Sabéis de dónde vienen las manzanas
o las naranjas que comemos?
No me refiero a su procedencia
geográfica, sino a si sabéis
cómo se generan, cómo se origina.
Si pudiéramos rebobinar a cámara rápida
y ver cómo se originan las frutas
y verduras que comemos a diario,
comprobaríamos que en muchas de ellas
ha intervenido un polinizador animal
o lo que coloquialmente
conocemos como un bicho
que se ha encargado de reunir los gametos
masculinos y femeninos de una flor
para dar lugar a un fruto.
Dentro de este término “bicho” se
incluyen, además de muchos animales,
un gran número de especies de insectos.
De todas ellas, las abejas
son las más importantes.
Más del 75% de las plantas
y cultivos del mundo necesitan una abeja
para poder reproducirse y generar
en consecuencia esos alimentos
que forman parte
de nuestra dieta habitual.
Lo más triste de todo esto
es que nosotros mismos
con la agricultura intensiva
de monocultivos,
el uso masivo de pesticidas
o todo lo que conlleva el cambio climático
estamos dificultando
cada vez más su existencia.
En este mismo momento hay especies
de polinizadores que están desapareciendo
por nuestra culpa.
Sin abejas no tendríamos
las manzanas o las naranjas
de las que os acabo de preguntar.
Pero tampoco tendríamos melones,
melocotones, coliflor,
zanahorias, cebollas, calabacín,
cacao o café.
Y atención a todos los que en este
momento estáis pensando:
¡Pobres vegetarianos y veganos!
Porque sin abejas tampoco
tendríamos otras muchas plantas
que son la base
de la alimentación del ganado.
Es decir, la producción cárnica
también se vería afectada.
Actualmente, la abeja melífera,
la que podemos considerar domesticada,
la que los apicultores utilizamos como
animal ganadero,
se ha convertido en uno de los principales
polinizadores en agricultura.
Tanto es así, que se estima
que en torno a un 80 % de la polinización
corre a cargo de esta abeja.
Pero no nos engañemos,
las abejas no polinizan altruistamente
de forma desinteresada
para que nosotros podamos
comer manzanas o naranjas.
Para ellas, la polinización es algo
secundario que se produce,
podríamos decir, por accidente.
Fuera de la colmena,
las abejas se dedican fundamentalmente
a recolectar alimentos
para mantener a la colonia.
Hay abejas que se encargan
de recolectar polen
y otras que recolectan néctar
visitando millones de flores, a montones.
Así, cuantas más, mejor.
A lo loco.
El caso es que, mientras
están realizando este trabajo,
los pelos que cubren el cuerpo
de las abejas
atraen con energía electrostática los
pequeños granos de polen de las flores.
Todos sabéis que son los gametos
masculinos de la flor.
Esos granos de polen quedan
adheridos a su cuerpo
y las abejas lo que hacen es compactarlos
formando bolitas de mayor tamaño
para transportarlas a la colmena.
Para la recolección del néctar,
sin embargo, la abeja se tiene
que esforzar un poquito más.
¿Por qué?
Porque las flores,
que también son muy listas,
tienen sus reservorios de néctar,
sus nectarios, escondidos
cerquita de su órgano
reproductor femenino: el ovario.
¿Qué sucede?
Que cuando la abeja hace
su recorrido para buscar el néctar,
es muy probable que esos pequeños granos
de polen que tenía adheridos a sus pelos
entren en contacto con
la parte femenina de la flor.
De este modo, se inicia la fecundación
y, a partir de ahí, la generación
de un nuevo fruto.
Pero como se estaba diciendo,
a las abejas no les preocupa,
lo más mínimo, lo de polinizar o no.
Su preocupación fundamental es volver
a la colmena cargadas de alimento.
El polen será su fuente principal de
proteínas, lípidos, vitaminas y minerales.
Y el néctar será su fuente
principal de energía
una vez deshidratado
y transformado en miel.
Las abejas visitan
más de cuatro millones de flores
para producir un solo kilo de miel.
Impresionante, ¿verdad?
Pero es que una abeja,
a lo largo de su vida,
sólo es capaz de producir
una doceava parte
de una cucharilla en miel.
Y hablando de miel,
porque es a lo que yo venía.
Me voy enrollando
y no me decís nada...
Yo creo que existe una miel perfecta
para cada uno de nosotros
y que en el fondo a todos
nos gusta la miel
aunque hay algunos que todavía
no lo han descubierto.
En el mundo existen tantas
variedades de miel tan diferentes
en aromas, sabores, colores, texturas,
que parece casi imposible
que alguien no encuentre
una miel que le guste.
Desde las más neutras, las más suaves
como pueden ser la miel de alfalfa,
la miel de algodón o la miel de acacia
hasta las más potentes,
las que tienen más carácter
como pueden ser la miel de aguacate,
la miel de castaño o la miel de brezo,
pasando por todas esas mieles que son más
aromáticas o más espaciadas
como pueden ser la miel de eucalipto,
la miel de pino o la miel de cilantro.
Sin desmerecer para nada
una buena miel multifloral.
Además de diferentes características,
estas variedades de miel
presentan diferentes composición
y por lo tanto diferentes propiedades.
Voy a haceros una confesión:
Yo soy defensora a ultranza
del consumo de miel de calidad.
Pero es verdad que no llego a los niveles
de aquellos que la definen
como un súper alimento
o algo casi milagroso.
Nutricionalmente hablando,
la miel por eso es dulce.
Es una solución
sobresaturada de azúcares.
Y en los tiempos que corren,
como ya habéis visto,
hablar de eso es casi como
hablar de un alimento satánico.
Muchos alegan que los azúcares de la miel
son completamente diferentes
al azúcar de mesa: la sacarosa.
Y es verdad, tienen razón.
Los azúcares de la miel fundamentalmente
son glucosa y fructosa
que son monosacáridos que nuestro cuerpo
asimila y metaboliza rápidamente.
Pero, al fin y al cabo, son azúcares.
Sin embargo, mientras que
el azúcar de mesa es solo sacarosa
en la miel existen otros compuestos.
Además de agua, hay vitaminas,
minerales, compuestos fenólicos,
sustancias que aporta la propia abeja,
fundamentalmente enzimas digestivas,
y así un largo etcétera hasta
más de 200 compuestos diferentes.
Evidentemente, están en
concentraciones muy pequeñas,
por eso una miel nunca podría
sustituir a un kiwi o a una naranja
para cubrir nuestras necesidades
diarias de vitamina C.
Pero esos compuestos están ahí.
Por lo tanto, la miel podría ser,
con moderación,
un sustituto perfecto del azúcar
y no dejarla solo para cuando
estamos enfermos,
sino utilizarla para endulzar
el yogur, el café por las mañanas
o incluso una infusión relajante
antes de irnos a dormir.
Es por eso que también me enerva ver en
Instagram, en Twitter, leer en titulares:
“La gran mentira de la miel”.
Porque la miel que no ha recibido
un tratamiento térmico,
ha demostrado científicamente
tener propiedades antioxidantes,
ayudar y favorecer a la regeneración
y curación de tejidos.
Por eso nos calma cuando nos duele
la garganta o cuando tenemos tos,
e incluso ser más eficaz
que algunos antibióticos
en la lucha contra bacterias resistentes.
Sin embargo, para tener todas
estas ventajas, estos beneficios,
la miel tiene que ser, como
hemos dicho, una miel de calidad.
Es decir, una miel que haya sido extraída
y procesada en condiciones
higiénicas adecuadas,
que no haya sufrido tratamientos térmicos
que alteren su composición
y que no haya sido mezclada con nada.
Vamos, que sea miel.
Desgraciadamente, en España
exportamos más del 75%
de nuestra producción anual de miel
a países como Francia, Italia o Alemania
que valoran nuestro producto
por su calidad.
Al mismo tiempo importamos
la misma cantidad de miel
procedente de otros países,
principalmente China, Uruguay o Argentina.
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
Es decir, mientras la miel española
se comercializa en los países vecinos,
los españoles consumimos mayoritariamente,
y como reza la etiqueta,
mezclas de mieles procedentes
y no procedentes de la Unión Europea
cuyo precio de compra además
ronda a los dos euros el kilo.
Yo también me pregunto muchas veces
si será realmente miel
eso que estamos comprando.
Comprar una miel de calidad
no es tan difícil como puede parecer.
Huir de las grandes superficies,
centrarnos en buscar miel
en las tiendas del barrio, de productos
de proximidad, en mercados locales,
o adquirirla directamente al apicultor
o la apicultura de confianza
siempre es una garantía.
Siempre es una garantía adicional.
El precio, además, es
un indicador muy bueno.
Una miel que sea muy barata
probablemente no sea miel.
Por otro lado, el etiquetado también
nos puede ayudar a conocer su origen.
La normativa actual
obliga a hacer un listado
del o los países de origen de esa miel.
Si una miel es 100 % española,
pues ya no hay dudas.
Y una cosa más.
Si con el tiempo la miel
se endurece, cristaliza, solidifica,
no es que se haya estropeado
ni que le hayan añadido azúcar.
Quiere decir que es una miel de calidad.
Es una miel que no ha sufrido
un tratamiento térmico y que por lo tanto,
conserva todos esos compuestos
que la hacen diferente del azúcar.
Y ya para terminar,
voy a pediros solo dos cosas.
La primera, es que la próxima vez
que vayáis a comprar miel
os fijáis muy bien en su origen
y que como consumidores decidáis
qué tipo de miel queréis comprar.
Y la segunda es, que cuando vayáis a comer
una cucharada de miel
os paráis un instante y penséis.
Penséis que esa sustancia dulce,
pegajosa y deliciosa
es la esencia de millones de flores,
de paisajes infinitos
y de la gran dedicación
y trabajo de las abejas.
Así que, valoradla como
se merece y disfrutadla.
Muchas gracias.